ambiance musicale table dressée tenue de
soirée les élus du cœur ont convié leur
généreux donateurs pour une soirée de
gala aux pyramides du Port-Marly cette
association fondée par les maires de
Villepreux et du Port-Marly a pour but
de rassembler différentes forces
qu'elles soient politiques associatives
ou citoyenne autour d'oeuvres
caritatives et humanitaires ce gars-là
c'est une des actions une action phare
notamment de notre projet une histoire
de coeur qui a pour objectif de lever
des fonds pour sauver deux enfants
malades du cœur au profit de
l'association Mécénat Chirurgie
Cardiaque cette aventure elle est née de
la folie d'un homme cet homme qui se
trouve juste à côté de moi qui parmi les
nombreuses idées qui peut avoir a eu
celle-ci m'a proposé de trouver un moyen
d'allier
utile à l'agréable de poursuivre notre
mandat demeure en étant utile quelque
part la société et à travers une belle
cause l'objectif recueillir en tout
24000 euros mais c'est la chirurgie
cardiaque permet à des enfants atteints
de malformations cardiaques originaires
de pays défavorisés de de faire opérer
en France c'est les opérations à coeur
ouvert donc on va faire venir les
enfants ils vont attaquer dans des
familles d'accueil on a besoin on aura
besoin de famille d'accueil pour ses
enfants et on va financer les hôpitaux
et on a un forfait de 12000 euros pour
repérer ses enfants ils vont avoir une
petite convalescence dans la famille
d'accueil d'un mois et demi et après ils
vont rentrer chez eux ils vont galoper
jouer au foot à la marelle je sais bon
une vie d'enfant quoi c'est fantastique
dont la salle des personnalités
politiques venue soutenir les élus du
cœur j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour
l'énergie qui veulent consacrer à cette
belle cause et c'est la raison pour
laquelle tout naturellement je suis venu
ce soir y apporter une une modeste
contribution que ce soit un maire que ce
soit citoyen qui s'implique vis-à-vis
une association je pense que on est tous
citoyens avant tout mais aussi d'anciens
footballeurs qui souhaitent mettre leur
notoriété au service de cette action
souvent on reproche un homme politique
de parler de parler et pas d'agir et
pour une fois qu'on a
deux mers qui qui prennent une
initiative et qui décide d'agir
justement et ben nous on se doit d'être
présent et on se doit de les soutenir
c'est important de de redonner quand on
a eu la chance d'avoir un peu de joie
j'ai 10 ans sa vie il faut être capable
de redonner et de de donner un coup de
main comme je disais pour pour faire
avancer les choses les élus du cœur se
rapprochent peu à peu du but après plus
de 4000 euros collectés cet été ce sont
9000 euros qui ont été récoltés lors de
cette soirée de gala et pour mettre en
lumière leur association il s'envoleront
aux Canaries pour participer au half
marathon des sables du 25 septembre 2
octobre